foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our regular news video this
week we bring you two new updates from
the Spider-Man universe in addition we
provide you with an extra large news
report on Deadpool 3 where you can find
out who the new bad guy in the upcoming
film could be and what the already
completed script for the Deadpool
Christmas movie is all about plus you
can expect exclusive images from Indiana
Jones 5 to new cast members for blade
and Dwayne Johnson's statement about DC
and finally there's some great news
about our website kenocheck.com so get
ready for this week's news
Spider-Man into the spider-verse
creators Phil Lord and Chris Miller
talked about their new animated film The
highly acclaimed animation style of the
first installment was one of the main
reasons for its huge success so it comes
as no surprise that Lord and Miller
focused mainly on the visuals in their
recent interview it was stated that the
sequel will use not just one but six
different animation Styles the audience
is expected to experience real wow
moments when switching between the
animations which are thematically
adapted to the movie fittingly there has
now been a close-up of a character
wearing the Spidey mask given the amount
of new characters it's impossible to say
Beyond a doubt whether it's Miles
Morales or someone else up to now
confirmed characters include Spider-Man
2099 Gwen Stacy spider Gwen Jessica Drew
as Spider Woman spider punk as well as
the villain spot the list will certainly
become even longer after all there's
still a bit of time until the theatrical
release of Spider-Man across the
spider-verse on June 2nd 2023
filming of the upcoming blade is not
going very smoothly although green book
star mahershala Ali was found to be the
right person to play the main character
the previous director the Sam Tariq left
the production at the end of September
in the meantime a lot of valuable time
has passed after all the MCU film is
scheduled to be released in September of
2024 and has long had its fixed date in
the schedule of the MCU the latter is
not known for its flexibility and even
minor movie postponements can have a
huge impact on other projects that's why
the search for a new director was in
full swing in the past few weeks to
ensure that a blade movie is brought to
the big screen for the first time in
almost 25 years as The Hollywood
Reporter announced this week two
important positions have been filled on
the one hand Lovecraft country director
Jan demangie takes over the vacant
position of director while on the other
hand Colin and black and white writer
Michael starbury has been found as the
right person to rewrite the script
starberry is to pen a completely new
screenplay following Rumors in the past
actor Ali was a staunch opponent of the
previous script which was a mere 90
pages long now that the people
responsible for directing and writing
the screenplay have been determined the
production Pace will have to pick up
quite a bit in order to stick to the
release date without any issues filming
is scheduled to begin in Atlanta during
the course of next year with a
theatrical release date of September 6
2024.
ever since 1981 he has been swinging
over Rocky Canyons running away from
giant odors and always having to deal
with the Nazis we're talking of course
about Indiana Jones who has become the
world's most famous movie archaeologist
in four feature films to date soon the
fifth and final film in the series will
be released in movie theaters and one
wonders what figure the now 80 year old
Ford will cut in his often physically
challenging role a first public trailer
was unfortunately not yet granted to the
fan Community this week however Empire
magazine provided a few exclusive images
and further information about the
upcoming Blockbuster the images show
Indie and his stepdaughter mads
Mickelson as a Nazi villain as well as
exclusive covers that will Grace
upcoming issues of Empire additionally
there were some exciting details about
Indiana Jones 5. as you can already tell
from the secret set shots as well as
mads Mickelson's character Indiana Jones
will once again meet some Nazis however
the film is actually set in 1969 and
thus almost 25 years after the Third
Reich thus events from 1944 and the late
1960s will be combined as director James
mangle confirmed to Empire in addition
many ex-nazis are involved as scientists
in the so-called space race between the
Soviet Union and the United States among
them is mads Mickelson's character
baller who for all of his enthusiasm for
space has an agenda all his own for the
opening sequence a kind of flashback to
the Raiders of the Lost Arc times as
planned for which the main character is
digitally rejuvenated after last week's
rumors we were denied by director
Mangold that the test screenings had
gone very bad the mood among fans now
seems to be more optimistic again we are
excited to see the cast around Harrison
Ford as Indie Phoebe Waller Bridge as
Helena mads Mickelson as baller and John
Rhys Davies as Salah the trailer will
probably be released within the next
couple of days or weeks Indiana Jones 5
is then scheduled to open in theaters on
June 30th 2023
only a few weeks ago it was confirmed
that Hugh Jackman would return as
Wolverine in the upcoming Deadpool 3.
now that the initially gigantic hype is
slowly dying down there are already
rumors about another well-known
character that might show up the talk is
about Wolverine's daughter Lara who was
also known as x-23 she was played by
Daphne Keane in 2017's last installment
of the Wolverine series Logan and she
may now be reprising her role the rumors
originated in the wake of a statement
from Insider Grace Randolph in a video
she spoke of Kevin feige using the
Multiverse Saga to retire the original
X-Men and put together his own MCU
conforming version in the process she
went into more detail about the possible
return of Daphne Keen as x-23 though
whether or not her claims are true will
surely be revealed soon others assume
that Keen will not appear until Avengers
secret War however this Theory should
equally be taken with a grain of salt
other news about Deadpool 3 concerns
Lady Death
considered to be the antagonist of the
X-Men and Wolverine as part of the
casting for Deadpool 3 the search is
said to have begun for an actress
between the ages of 30 and 50 to play a
major antagonist in the film fighting
against Wolverine and Deadpool Lady
Death is an extremely powerful character
and as her name suggests is the
personified death who is capable of
manipulating time and reality in the
comics she also had a special
relationship with Deadpool and Thanos
the latter in particular was hopelessly
in love with her she on the other hand
was more attracted to Deadpool since he
is Immortal and Lady Death therefore had
no chance of getting a hold of his soul
another possibility would be euriko
oyama AKA Lady Deathstrike who has a
very similar name and is also under
discussion her last appearance was in
X-Men 2 which was almost 20 years ago at
the moment there is a lot of speculation
among fans and it is not quite sure who
will be right in the end the third and
final piece of news from the franchise
is not so much about the upcoming third
Deadpool movie but one that has already
been been written but will probably
never come out it is a Christmas special
that lead actor Reynolds has put on
paper together with producers rep Rhys
and Paul wernick Reflections on the film
are said to have taken place prior to
the Disney acquisition of fox but were
left behind during the Disney merger
whether and in what context this film
will possibly be produced after the
release of Deadpool 3 is unclear for now
we have to wait for the theatrical
release of the third Deadpool movie
which is scheduled for November 8 2024
which Deadpool news were you most
excited about this week and who could
you easily imagine in the female villain
role let us know in the comments
foreign
it has been known since September of
2020 that Sony is working on several
series for various Spider-Man characters
in addition to the Cinematic expansion
of the Sony Spider-Man universe as was
recently made known the first series
project is now being set in motion it is
titled silk spider society and deals
with the eponymous Marvel heroine Cindy
Moon AKA silk she shares a similar fate
to Peter Parker as she too was bitten by
a radioactive spider likewise she
developed some spider-like superpowers
and even has a very special connection
to her male counterpart Peter Parker
which will surely be addressed in the
series silk is one of the newer Marvel
characters and was created by dance slot
and Umberto Ramos she has however
previously made appearances in
Spider-Man homecoming and Avengers
Infinity War where she was played by
Tiffany espinson it is not clear whether
she will return to her role or whether
they will recast the super heroine the
first of many Spider-Man spin-offs from
Sony will be showrun by Angela Kang who
currently occupies the same position on
The Walking Dead the script was penned
by Dash and Lily writer Lauren Moon
while the series will be produced by
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
creators Phil Lord and Chris Miller the
series is expected to run in the United
States on MGM plus depending on how
quickly further cast and crew signings
progress in early 2024 release date
seems likely
when Hollywood star Dwayne Johnson
uploaded an almost seven minute video on
Wednesday many asked themselves what
important things the 50 year old had to
say first he praised his film Black Adam
which is currently playing in theaters
and the fact that the Justice Society of
America is now known to a wider audience
thanks to him however this was followed
Above All by sharp words in the
direction of former DC management
according to him it was inexplicable and
equally unforgivable that the studio did
not bring back Henry Cavill as Superman
earlier through years of persuasion he
said he and Dany as well as Hiram Garcia
of his production company seven bucks
succeeded in bringing back Henry Cavill
into the DC Universe one of Johnson's
biggest Rivals within DC was Walter
Hamada who was still the president of DC
until a few weeks ago now that Hamada
has moved on to Paramount Pictures
nothing stands in the way of a Man of
Steel sequel with Cavill due largely to
Johnson's Relentless efforts many fans
will surely appreciate this as Cabell is
an absolute favorite among fans and
shaped character of Superman in a
similar manner to Christopher Reeve in
his early days as Clark Kent we are
definitely looking forward to the
upcoming movie around Cavill Superman
and are looking forward to more updates
a release date has not been fixed yet
an awesome new feature awaits you on our
website kinnocheck.com you can Now swipe
from trailer to trailer on your
smartphone just like on Tick Tock making
it really quick and simple to find the
best videos give it a try
thank you foreign
[Music]